hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whack the creeps the
latest edition in the long line of games
of barely justifiable homicide and you
guys know the drill it's gonna be bloody
and horrible and violence so if you're
not keen on that stuff don't watch it
kiss is about to be a lot of blood oh I
like the way you laugh without moving
your lips it really is a very endearing
to you and I'm so glad that obviously we
bond together because we enjoy wanton
murder so wait my hair guy with the
spike oh thank you bartender who is
oddly okay with watching this lady
murder these two people in horrible
fashion you got to clean the blood up
off the floor everything is okay this
book okay my goodness gracious oh yeah
taser oh boy okay yeah don't worry about
it
Oh oh this is gonna be a loop over and
over oh no never mind
all right no lipstick okay you know
you're incredibly creative here if
you're able to murder these people with
such normal everyday objects who carries
explosive lipstick what if it goes off
while you're applying it it blew your
brains out that's horrible
[Applause]
okay completed secret agent know what
that means what do you mean secret agent
is that because of the lipstick I don't
understand hmm
object requires a second to work what do
you mean dartboard of course yeah this
is gonna be fun to come join me it's
gonna be totally cool okay well that's a
quite a powerful throw you got there if
you made it go all the way through his
head I'm very impressed and also I'm
disgusted but mostly impressed
bull's eye I don't care about these
achievements they're all horrible
again oh I thought that was in the balls
again well I guess that didn't kill him
oh no totally fine and he's gonna wake
up to find the puddle of blood that was
once his friend could there possibly be
more are you gonna finish him off - okay
once again another guy totally find it
alive and this guy just seems to be the
magnet for murder oh yeah beer boarding
oh that's a pleasant achievement I'm so
happy that I got that
is everything fine everything's fine one
of these days I want to go into this Oh
hand
perfectly ordinary and non-deadly hat
it's gonna be fine everyone zero
[Music]
bartender why do you let that in your
place of establishment bar I just my my
engineering brain is trying to find the
logic out of it why were you prepared
for war when you went into this bar my
goodness
already done protect yourself from the
shower of blood my goodness
this is unnecessary it's unholy jukebox
what do we got I'm now becoming numb to
the pain it's all fine for you ah thank
you again another employee that I've
never seen before that didn't care those
murdering them a million times in a
million other ways why did these people
come to this bar in the first place ball
ball ball pool ball you guys wanna play
some pool you boys want to play yeah
totally innocent don't think anything of
it it's totally fine that hurt a lot oh
okay well Ngata me I'm pretty sure
that's not how that would have worked
and I don't know why he kept his head on
the table for us to be able to ram down
his throat you weren't even looking at
the drink when you took a drink of it
that didn't make any sense
q+ oh yes this will be the murder that
I've always desired none
[Applause]
oh there was a deception chica helped
saved me from this horrible murder this
bloody experience yeah you just stand
there don't worry about well I don't
think he's dead yet falstaff yeah
bouncer these creeps have been giving me
trouble you should just throw them out
[Laughter]
let's go up on the roof hey boys am i
gonna punch him testicular region oh my
friend will see you to bed ten minutes
later oh boy I thought that's your
girlfriend up there I thought you went
to the bathroom or something
what do you okay whatever oh he went to
go have a snoop pencil oh hey would you
like my number all innocuous and
innocent I'm sure this is gonna go
lovely for you
[Music]
you don't need a magic trick you just
get death apparently please don't stomp
on his balls no that's what you get and
this is what you get
he gets oh no he got a slight pursed in
the face it's too much for my fragile
brain
oh my innocent eyes what are they doing
being subjected to this [ __ ] or
there anything else in my purse Oh
pepper spray I didn't even see that for
pepper spray a non-lethal solution
hopefully usually
[Applause]
again our non-lethal solution to smack
him upside the head with the final kill
the last call in cover and shield my
eyes from the boy yeah buddy yeah friend
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Oh
oh [ __ ] that he moonwalks once more and
in the breach okay that's a nice
decoration keeping the bar everybody
friends good to see you again
enjoy experiences together and share
memories revolve coming soon whacked a
serial killer
okay that seems like someone who might
maybe deserve this punishment I guess
for the first time in the cities of this
game the funny thing is like why oh man
there's never bite I have no words of
wisdom to say at the end of this episode
all I'll say is thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to see the
rest of the series of this game you can
find it link in the description with the
playlist it's got them all in there a
bunch of bloody gory intense action for
you all to enjoy
[Music]
was mean